it's time for presented by I know one
double Ernie unsullied by sponsorship as
possible in 1989 Harrison so Chuck's
here Kenny is smiley in his ring we are
we are in a legit wrestling ring well
I'll show you in just a second but
Shaquille O'Neill actually has some
experience in the wrestling ring and
getting into the ring so we figured he
needs a little bit of a build-up before
we go in there yes so ladies and
gentlemen oh he's got two belts he
thinks for some reason the guy on the
bottom of the fight is winning
oh how are you gonna get into the ring
big oh my gosh I want to see how you get
into real Emma see the Belkin are you
gonna take the traditional stairs or no
oh we gonna hold a belt fight there you
go here you get you net eight you don't
know about belts and rings brother oh
[Applause]
why you grabbing me so what are we doing
okay here's what we're doing on Saturday
night Chris Jericho defenses all elite
wrestling world championship title
against Cody Rhodes and here tonight
Chris Jericho joins us guys are far away
[Applause]
this is great I don't know if you know
what you're getting into here tonight
Chris Chris you gotta let us know if
this ringers with let me tell you it's
funny when I was a kid
every time at the rusty matches during
intermission all the little kids would
get in the ring yeah and start jumping
around and bouncing around let's see you
guys remind me you know what we are you
know what this reminds me of this takes
us back in the early days of when when
Turner used to have like live Atlanta
wrestling right oh and the the ring was
actually in the other studio Wow to Joe
and Ted Turner would come downstairs
sometimes and be walking around while
guys were wrestling and putting the show
studio wrestling there's an old school
thing exactly well I've been arrested
fan for a long time I go back to the
four horsemen the guys like hey so
listen you've been this thing a long
time when did it kick in to you is your
personality because the Restless that's
just half of it or less yet less than
half when did you get into what your
personality you like I need to be this
personality well connecting with the
crowd is the most important thing it's
show business right if not you're just
doing moves with suits you half-naked
guys with oil on rolling around with
each other look at that laughs the last
time I saw Shaq we're in a wrestling
ring well that's all jacked up
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
mic so you guys get paid a lot of money
to do that come to aw we'll pay you
millions on Saturday geez I mean the
cast is broken loose here in the studio
can it compare to what you've seen here
already I mean how can I compare with
this some of the greatest tell him not
to do that will you please he's gonna
break the ring please tell them not to
do that thing microphone is I've had
some western faux mattering things to
say about you in Charlotte the
connecting with the crowd and selling
the match pipe by talking people into
the into the arena is how it works so
the moves are important all that stuff
for the most important thing is the
connection look at this handsome devil
here and there's fire there look at that
sucker yeah let's do that the right boom
we're knocking guys out BAM boom so Cody
is dusty saw
son absolutely the one thing I've
learned about wrestling through
wrestling wrestling it's a lot of family
business yeah the second generation
third generation those type of things
and when you get a guy like Cody who
came up to the business now that he's
kind of an executive in aw he's really
kind of taken to that role and he really
is his father's son in a lot of
different ways so I'm not letting anyone
get behind me a little guy just hang out
with NBA players so how did you get into
eight you double w in one place what was
the draw company is owned by the Khan
family that owns the Jacksonville
Jaguars a good example fine people but
they start wanting to start a company
and what they offer that w/e didn't was
more creative freedom the chance to do
things he kissed me on the forehead
called me Christina last I remember that
in Washington he bent over and kissing
like Christie you know yes I mean it was
a chance to do something new and for the
first time in 20 years there was an
alternative to WV which is a good thing
because it gives fans more options gives
the guys better deals in and out of the
ring so um it just seemed to me after
all these years of doing this the one
thing that I'd never done which is
basically helps start a new company and
get it up and rolling this is what we've
done Cobb because me and Kenny we we
represent a wrestler who openly
represent his name is L underdog Oh
oh yeah
traditional research you know it's
interesting people have like when people
like you don't just walk off the street
and do what you do for a living yeah how
much training back when you first
started how much training was involved
well I mean you got to learn the basics
right and then you just got to go
through it's like playing basketball you
guys start on a court it's in somebody's
backyard or whatever in the street
rustling you have to learn how to take
the falls how to take the bumps as we
call them what you guys were doing and
then once you learn the skills then you
have to get in there and do like we said
I grew up in that first era Bruno
Sammartino and Andre the Giant or Buki
mr. referee is the wrestler who did you
wrestling fan before yeah I grew up in
Winnipeg which was AWA which is where
Hulk Hogan started okay the ganya family
ran that once that's why I started so
I've known you guys forever right why is
it you know you go to Bret the Hitman
Hart and all those guys why is it all
you guys are from Canada what is the
what is the thing something in the beer
like to drink beer and fight and not
necessarily that order I don't know what
it is maybe because it's a smaller
company a smaller country but there is a
lot of great Russell's yeah I'm from
Canada from Calgary from Winnipeg from
Toronto it's almost a tradition I don't
know what it is
I probably per capita Canada might have
the best wrestlers in the world agree
yeah [ __ ] one's Rob
there is so tough the second my gosh
good luck on Saturday night good luck to
you guys in this row oh my goodness that
is ever like I feel like sky Lolo in
here right